CONNOR McDAVID AND THE OILERS.
ABOUT TIME THERE
SHOT HERE, SKIP OUT BYE MINORS.
THERE TO GET A SHOT THE
DEFLECTS OFF GAS. OR THE
OILERS.
SHOT GOES WIDE OFF TO THE SIDE
OF
DARNELL FORCES THE TEAM TO
WELL OFF.
KI
GETTING SOME BOOKS HERE IN.
NOW, MANAGEMENT. REST OF THE GA
ONCE HE CAME BACK.
THE OILERS OUTPLAYED CAROLINA.
SENT HIM INTO THE CORNER.
ALSOCASTER
51 SECONDS REMAIN ON THE FIRST
PENALTY.
THEY D
NOW THE OILERS ESCAPE THE
CENTER.
MOVING ON
NOW GOING ON, GETTING IT DOWN
LOW W G TO BREAK OVERALL.
PLAYING THEM WELL.
LOSE THE PUCK.
HIGH IN THE NET.
LARRABEE. ING AT 91
IN THE MIDDLE RIGHT THERE.
HIGH-RISE SHOT DRAISAISEPARATE
WHAT WOULD YOU GUESS?
>> ANYTIME YOU HAVE TWO GREAT
PLAYERS THAT SINK  DOORSTEP.
YOU SEE KOSKINEN RIGHT THERE.
PUSHED INTO CONNOR HART.
GOT  ACROSS AN BACK OFF THE PLA
WATCHING HIM DEFENSIVELY HERE,
THE HAND EYE COORDINATION,
THERE IS THE.
SHOT DEFLECTED TO QUITE THERE.S
THERE A
HURRY.
NO PROBLEM WITH THE GAME
ATKINSON BACK TOWARDS THE POINT.
I FOR GIROUX. .
HERE'S A PLAY BY KOSKINEN
TAKING THE PAD OUT.
COMING UP WORST  PLAYOFFS
BEGAN.
THERE HE I I GET THE
OTHETOUCHED THE POT
BEFORE IT POPPED INTO THE NET.